ils étaient une centaine ce midi à
manifester pour leurs droits ces
travailleurs sans papier sont venus
réclamer la régularisation de leur
situation au groupe Sodexo situé à
guillancour des salariés pour beaucoup
licenciés par l'entreprise pour défaut
de papier selon la CGT aujourd'hui il
risque l'expulsion tout travail doit
être reconnu et notamment pour les sans
papier ben ça veut dire que l'employeur
assume ses responsabilités et donne les
les documents nécessaires on a déjà
déposé plus de 205 dossiers en
préfecture qui sont en cours de
traitement donc ça devient urgent
d'avoir les documents pour compléter le
dossier la CGT affirme avoir voulu
entamer les discussions avec le groupe
il y a plusieurs mois mais sans retour
les manifestants souhaitent récupérer
les attestations permettant de
reconnaître leur travail et de rester
sur le territoire c'est le cas d'Ibrahim
arrivé en France il y a 6 ans toute ma
vie en France donc je vais rester en
France et comme mes collègues aussi ils
ont travaillé ici ils ont par
au développement de ce pays aujourd'hui
aussi ils sont intégrés d'une manière
normale donc je vois pas pourquoi ne pas
être régularisé il nous faut mieux
comprendre le sujet il nous faut donc
écouter les gens on a une tradition dans
le groupe qui est l'écoute de nos
collaborateurs on va l'appliquer donc ce
que nous allons faire là on s'est
entendu avec avec les les représentants
des collaborateurs pour pour pouvoir
recevoir des gens qui qui qui qui sont
désignés par le groupe
les travailleurs continueront leur
mouvement tant qu'ils n'obtiendront pas
satisfaction actuellement le dialogue se
poursuit entre les deux parties en
France selon les estimations entre 200
et 400000 personnes vivraient en
situation
irrégulière